alors oui j'ai c'est plein de
configurations différentes
je suis revenu un truc un peu plus de
rente en glace et je trouve ça plus
jolie je trouve ça plus sympa et c'est
pas du tout le sujet de cette vidéo
c'est le sujet de cette vidéo c'est un
truc que j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me
dise avant que je démarre la vidéo et et
surtout dont je vais vous parler juste
après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
vidéo
et puis si vous êtes nouveau sur la
chaîne ici on parle de création de
vidéos de montage de captation d'astuces
en tout genre donc si c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner il y aura certainement des
choses qui vont vous intéressez sur
cette chaîne dans le passé dans l'avenir
voilà il ya des choses qui peuvent eux
qui peuvent le faire aujourd'hui j'avais
envie de vous parler de cinq choses que
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me dise avant
que je démarre la vidéo et que
j'apprenne un petit peu par ci par là
plein de petites choses boutabout qui
font que j'ai quand même perdu beaucoup
de temps et si je les avais su avant
j'aurais perdu beaucoup moins de temps
c'est un peu comme si je disais si on
était parti à 15 minutes on serait là
depuis un quart d'heure parce que
certainement comme vous j'ai appris tout
seul
la vidéo principalement sur youtube ou
en côtoyant d'autres vidéaste donc en
gros j'ai fait un petit peu mon marché
un à droite à gauche j'ai appris des
choses j'ai fait plein d'erreurs que
j'ai corrigé par la suite
et justement c'est savoir j'aimerais
vous en parler pour que vous ne fassiez
pas à votre tour et puis que vous
gagneriez pas que moi j'ai galéré
ah et puis je dis ça il toujours ma
formation sur final cut aussi qui peut
vous aider à - galéré sur le montage et
à bien apprendre les bases et et tout ça
première chose que j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on me dise avant que je commence
avant que je me lance dans la vidéo
c'est tout simplement que tout se joue
au tournage
je m'explique souvent on a tendance à
penser bon l'exposition était pas
folichonne à l'homme la g1 pas très très
bien cadré et tout ça je vais me
rattraper en poste je vais rattraper sur
mon logiciel
je vais forcément arriver à bidouiller
un truc c'est pas grave si le plan il
n'est pas extraordinaire ça vaut pas le
coup leur faire et bien ça c'est une
énorme erreur
c'est une énorme erreur parce que tout
se jouera au moment où vous tournez vos
images
le plus important il est là il vaut
mieux passer du temps à refaire des
images si on en est pas satisfait il
vaut mieux passer du temps à préparer
les images qu'on va tourner
plutôt que de se dire bon je verrai je
verrai ça au montage ça va le faire ça
va pas senna au montage on peut
récupérer des trucs on peut recadrer on
peut retravailler l'exposition on peut
faire
la colorimétrie etc mais ça vaudra
jamais une bonne captation la meilleure
image que vous pourrez tirer ça sera pas
en l'art travaillant sur votre logiciel
ça sera en l'ajoutant correctement donc
n'hésitez pas à refaire plusieurs fois
les scènes à regarder éventuellement
même à vider vos cartes dans un ordi
pour voir sur un plus grand écran parce
que les les petits écrans de nos caméras
de nos dslr n'est pas forcément fou fou
c'est pas ça qui va vous donner vraiment
exactement le rendu final
donc n'hésitez pas à prendre le temps
quand vous foutez vous passerez aussi
beaucoup moins de temps après à monter
et vous galérez - et vous tirerez
sûrement le meilleur des conditions de
tournage que vous
deuxième conseil attendez avant
d'acheter du matériel parce que oui on
est toujours hyper tentait d'aller
regarder d'airé view il se dira avec tel
appareil jeffrey forcément de meilleurs
vidéos à celui-là il fait du 120 images
par seconde à celui-ci
ces deux-là 4k cas de 2 10 bits et ou
non c'est pas forcément ça qui fera que
vous ferez de meilleures images la
qualité de vos vidéos elle dépend en
grande partie de vous beaucoup plus que
de votre appareil et c'est une erreur
que moi j'ai fait j'ai acheté du
matériel
et puis comme au début j'avais pas non
plus un budget faramineux toujours pas
forcément le cas non plus bas j'ai
acheté des choses en me disant ouais bon
ben ça passera ça va suffire
même s'il n'a pas tout ce que je veux
dans bros tant pis c'est pas grave je
prends celui-là justement c'est moi qui
ferai la vidéo est là aussi c'est une
erreur parce que ben il aurait mieux
valu à ce moment là que je shoote avec
ce que j'avais et que je mette de côté
pour m'acheter vraiment la caméra que je
voulais l'appareil photo que je voulais
parce qu'au final pas j'ai acheté
quelque chose qui me convenait pas
forcément parce qu'il n'y avait pas
toutes les fonctionnalités que je
voulais donc j'ai revendu et forcément
quand on achète et qu'on vend
ben on y perd et après j'ai acheter
autre chose mais je me suis dit braille
je vais pas craquer non plus dans un
truc de fou qui coûte hyper cher je vais
prendre juste un petit peu au dessus et
l'a même problème mais au final on est
un peu frustré parce qu'on n'a pas les
fonctionnalités qu'on veut donc on
revient encore donc la perte au final
d'argent
l'achat la revente etc si j'avais acheté
directement le boîtier qui m'intéressait
ben j'aurais économiser beaucoup
d'argent puisque au final je les
achetais mais en ayant fait de détour et
en ayant perdu de l'argent en achetant
d'autres matériels et en leur vendant
par la suite donc il vaut mieux passer
du temps avec même un smartphone si
c'est tout ce que vous avez pour
l'instant et mettre tous les mois de
côté de l'argent pour pouvoir vous
achetez la caméra qui vous plaît une
caméra qui sera pas obsolète une caméra
qui aura toutes les fonctionnalités que
vous voulez plutôt que de se dire bon
ben je vais faire petit à petit parce
qu'au final on finit par dépensé
beaucoup plus d'argent que si on avait
attendu et qu'on avait acheté la caméra
qu'on vous la troisième chose que
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me dise et
surtout qu'on fasse rentrer méchamment
dans le cerveau avant de commencer la
vidéo c'est que préparer un tournage
c'est souvent beaucoup plus long que le
tournage en lui-même préparé notre
tournage ça prend énormément de temps et
ça prend énormément de réflexion quand
vous partez tourné à moins que ce soit
un événement sur lequel vous avez aucune
information ce cas là c'est qu'il ya un
problème de bruit fou des choses comme
ça il faut préparer ce que vous allez
shooter savoir quel matériel vous allez
utiliser
quel type de plan vous avez utilisé
qu'est ce que votre client veut au final
comme résultat est ce qu'il ya un
scénario est ce qu'il ya des figurants
voilà tout toutes ces choses là il faut
les prendre en compte et en fonction de
ça vous allez prendre le matériel
nécessaire à ce qui va falloir un game
boy est-ce que vous aurez suffisamment
de batterie est ce que vous allez avoir
besoin d'un téléobjectif
est ce qu'il y aura une prise de son
voilà tout ça c'est des choses qui
prennent énormément de temps à préparer
souvent on se dit bon je prends tout je
verrai sur place et on peut se retrouver
pris au dépourvu bah parce qu'on n'a pas
anticipé tout simplement et même si des
fois on arrive à sortir des trucs super
en étant complètement l'improvisation
mais il ya quand même de grandes chances
qu en ayant bien préparer votre tournage
vous ayez un meilleur résultat que si
vous l'avez fait en deux ans la
quatrième chose que j'aurais bien aimé
savoir également quand on regarde un
petit peu youtube justement sur les
réglages de caméras sur ce qui est
préconisé
vous dis souvent il faut faire du full
manuel tint pas d'autofocus tout en
manuel obturation l'ouverture les iso
tout en manuel il faut tout contrôler et
ça je suis pas complètement d'accord
alors c'est sûr que dans le meilleur des
cas quand on a du temps ici par exemple
je suis dans le studio j'ai mon
éclairage artificiel que je peux régler
exactement comme je veux j'ai un énorme
retour pour vérifier symonds m'a mise au
point est fait bref je peux me passer de
ce que peut m'apporter la caméra en
termes techniques en termes semi
automatique attention il faut pas filmer
non plus sur le mode automatique foule
automatique parce que là ça risque de
faire des trucs un peu bizarres mais les
iso automatique
l'autofocus pourquoi s'en priver quand
ses performances vraiment ça c'est un
truc que je comprends pas l'autofocus
c'est sûr qu'il ya des fois ça peut être
pénible mais il suffit de le désactiver
pour pouvoir faire sa mise au point
quand on veut un plan particulier et
quand ces d'autofocus ne veut
pas aller faire le point sur ce qu'on
souhaite mais 80% du temps ça fait bien
le job
les iso automatique dans certaines
circonstances si on met pas de filtre
end et notamment ça peut aussi être très
utile quand on blogue par exemple et
qu'on n'a pas de retour bas on est
obligé de se fier aux is automatique
sinon on risque d'avoir quelque chose de
complètement sont exposés ou de
complètement surexposé parce qu'on peut
pas voir ce qui se passe et je dis pas
que les modes automatiques c'est la
panacée bien au contraire
le mieux c'est de pouvoir tout contrôler
et d'avoir tout en manuel on est bien
d'accord comme ça vous avez un contrôle
sur tout mais il faut pas s'interdire
non plus d'utiliser ces mots delà qui
sont souvent assez bien fait et qui
fonctionne relativement bien dans
certaines conditions enfin la cinquième
et dernière chose que j'aurais bien aimé
savoir c'est que les règles sont faites
pour être transgressée beaucoup de gens
vont vous dire il faut faire comme ça il
faut faire comme ça il faut utiliser la
règle des 180 degrés absolument si c'est
à dire light des 180 ° c si vous filmez
en 25 images par seconde
vous mettez un chanteur speed 1 1 50e
c'est des préconisations pour avoir un
certain résultat mais rien encore une
fois ne vous interdit de faire des
essais vous filmer une scène d'action le
1 50e
ça va être
dégueulasse parce que vous allez rien
voir y aura du flou partout si vous
voulez une action qui est bien fluide et
bien découpé sans aucun flou de bougé
ben bien sûr que vous allez monter le
shooteur speed et donc méfiez vous des
règles les règles il faut d'abord les
comprendre comprendre pourquoi elle est
là ils pas les appliquer sans réfléchir
parce que souvent vous allez pouvoir
détourner ou transgresser ces règles
pour obtenir un résultat qui va vous
ressemble et qui va surtout coller au
mieux à ce que vous voulez rendre niveau
émotion au niveau visuel on est dans
l'artistique et à des préconisations il
ya c'est sur des règles qui fonctionne
de manière générale mais il faut pas non
plus y rester collé est resté borné sur
ces règles là absolument il faut faire
comme ça il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
il ya autant de possibilités que votre
créativité vous le permet et voilà les
amis c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette vidéo elle vous aura
plu j'espère qu'elle vous aura fait
gagner du temps aussi parce que moi
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me dise tout ça
quand j'ai démarré donc bah je vous fais
part de tout ça je vous partage tout ça
si cette vidéo vous a plu d'ailleurs
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
celui que les états unis nous envient 1
le coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo
si c'est pas encore le cas vous pouvez
vous abonner vous pouvez activer la
cloche pour être notifiée me mettre dans
les commentaires aussi ce que vous avez
pensé de cette vidéo et puis aussi des
choses que vous voudriez partagé entre
vous un des astuces des choses que vous
auriez aimé qu'on vous dise avant de
démarrer
et puis moi je vous dis mais comme
d'habitude rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo c'est
pas mal comme ça l'ail est le l'ordi est
tout tout va bien je peux faire de la
petite rotation assez rigolo je n'avais
jamais joué avec la rotule et le son
doit être mieux il ya le petit je vous
montre la peuplent hop
il ya le petit chat mort juste ici voilà
qui pendent wind et est donc j'aime bien
ce studio j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de studios